hello there I'm John Oliver and this is
YouTube
meaning I'm probably coming up on your
screen right now between grainy footage
of Prince performing at the Superbowl
and a seven minute video of someone
taking things out of boxes because
apparently there's now an entire genre
of entertainment based on the last scene
of the movie se7en I'm talking to you
now because there is no new episode of
last week tonight this week so I wanted
to take a moment here on the internet to
set some things straight because here at
last week tonight we work hard to ensure
that everything I say is as accurate as
possible but inevitably despite our
diligence occasional errors do slip
through so in the interest of full
transparency
I'd like to retract some of the claims
that I've made in the past that have
turned out unfortunately to be false so
first let me correct a statement I made
recently when I said in error that the
United States purchased Alaska from the
grizzly bears 450 pounds of salmon that
is unexpectedly false I don't know how
that got by us Alaska was actually
purchased from the Russian Empire in
1867 although it didn't become a state
until 1959 Alaska is and this is true
both the largest and least densely
populated state in the Union it is not
however a wasteland devoid of morality
where the boundaries between human and
moose are blurry at best and in many
cases altogether non-existent that's not
something I said on the air it's just
something I believed in my heart it
turns out was inaccurate that's on me
I'll take that one moving on just a few
weeks ago I said and I quote myspace is
back baby
it's Tom time
I said it I said that I don't deny that
I said that unfortunately it seems that
I may have spoken too soon our research
staff obtained documents that indicate
my space is emphatically not actually
back and it is my sad duty to inform you
that it is not now nor was it ever Tom
time now my space does
technically still exist but it remains
an Internet graveyard populated by scar
bands that broke up seven years ago and
now you may have also recently seen me
refer to trains as buses that it
has it has been brought to my attention
that that is false
trains are actually airplanes that pee
sitting down again I'm truly sorry to
have misled anyone by stating otherwise
next retraction this is difficult a few
months ago I claimed that these blue
chips are actually made from sliced
Grover arms which at the time was widely
believed to be accurate but as a recent
Pro Publica
exposure he revealed the chips are
actually kind of purple and when they
dug deeper they uncovered that they're
actually made from thin shavings of
Barney's penis
at least at least we now know why his
genitals are missing the point is the
point I'm trying to make here is
Grover's fine Barney chopped up his tick
into chips but Grover is fine my deepest
apologies to Grover's family for any
confusion my early report may of course
and finally I'd like to take back
something that I said in a moment of
what was sheer anger last year I refer
to this collection of fish as idiots
morons dimwits boneheads dunces and
doofuses which I now regret so to the
entire fish community I offer a sincere
apology for not going further that's
right your slimy dip chips are attract
more attraction I hope all of you end up
in a chowder
that's all we have time for right now
I'll do my best to be a star and
accurate as possible then return to HBO
on September 9th until then good night
[Applause]